bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag
dépenses économie impôts investissements
nous allons évoquer le budget de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines pour 2020 quelles sont les
économies réalisées les investissements
insuffler quid de la dette et des impôts
on y répond et partout
[Musique]
mais pour commencer nous sommes allés
voir les saint quentinois fonds qu'ils
nous présentent leur budget pour
l'agglomération
à mon avis ce sera un peu plus dans la
partie
ce pas m du budget un petit peu dans des
salles de sport des patinoires des
piscines dans tout ce qui est centre de
loisirs et s'est concentré le budget sur
ben ce genre d'endroit que logement et
culture dans l'environnement l'écologie
le social embellir la commune
l'environnement tout où le développement
durable les priorités au quotidien
serait l'éducation mettre une partie
importante sur l'alimentation
voilà faire la cuisine sur place
privilégier le bio au niveau du social
pour les personnes âgées
tout ce qui est petite enfance notamment
la garde ça manque au quotidien dans la
plupart des villes de la région
parisienne toujours l'éducation comme
ses fans à l'heure actuelle il n'y a pas
mal 20,2 de numérique en fait dans les
écoles
en tout cas c'est en train d'arriver
[Musique]
transport rénovation énergétique des
logements aux constructions
environnement ces dernières années
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines a concentré ses investissements
dans le développement durable
[Musique]
de grands chantiers ont également été un
peu de ces le doublement du pont qui
schuller entre maurepas et la verrière
avec l'instauration d'une voie réservée
aux transports en commun en site propre
et le développement de la multimodalité
au sein des pôles gare
bientôt d'autres projets seront mises en
oeuvre comme l'enfouissement de la rn10
à trappes ou encore le doublement du
pont de la villedieu à est en cours
[Musique]
l'autre grand chantier celui de
l'éducation avec le développement du
numérique dans toutes les écoles du
territoire
une initiative récompensée par le prix
innovation urbaine par les
développements des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine
je pense que c'est une bonne chose parce
que forcément c'est notre présent ici ce
sera leur futur
donc il faut qu'ils apprennent à s'en
servir après je dirais que ça doit se
faire avec parcimonie parce qu il faut
aussi qu'ils apprennent les bases et
écrire écrire à la main mais forcément
oui c'est bien c'est bien français bien
d'aller de l'avant et c'est bien de les
former à sap
[Musique]
des investissements malgré la hausse des
contributions de l'agglomération au
fonds national de péréquation des
ressources intercommunales et communales
un mécanisme de redistribution
financière entre les collectivités bien
et moins bien lotis malgré tout
l'agglomération parvient à poursuivre
son désendettement
le pacte financier et fiscal de
solidarité adopté en 2016 fixé un
objectif de désendettement à hauteur de
4 millions d'euros par an fin 2019
le désendettement était de 17 millions
d'euros par rapport à 2018
une action qui permet d'éviter une
éventuelle remontée des taux et offre
des marges de manoeuvre pour 2020 cet
équilibre budgétaire a été saluée par l'
agence de notation standard and poor's
pour autant pas d'augmentation d'impôts
cette année encore ni pour les habitants
ni pour les entreprises ces entreprises
parmi lesquelles les plus grands groupes
ont choisi de s'implanter sur le
territoire et qui font la force
économique de l'agglomération
investissements désendettement et pas de
hausses d'impôts
moi ce sont que des bonnes nouvelles en
fait oui mais voilà après les baisses
successives des dotations de l'état la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation se
profilent des travaux des raisons certes
mais il faut trouver les sous ailleurs
donc après la question c'est où les
souvent être trop et ça veut dire une
rentrée d'argent en moins mais pour
qu'ils voient l'argent il vient pas du
sien donc il faut enlever que par parme
et de luz sur les vases communicants qui
va être impactée par cette
suppression de la taxe d'habitation et
quels sont donc les budgets qui vont
être impactés j'attends juste de voir
comment ça va se traduire parce que à
l'heure actuelle à 50 ans on a
bon service au niveau de l'enfance au
niveau de plein plein de choses et
aujourd'hui beaucoup apparemment de
maires de villes de communes etc se
plaint justement de manquer d'argent
pour gérer leur connu pouvoir après ce
que ça donnerait si on va pas perdre des
services aussi par rapport à l'autre au
four de vie actuel depuis 2018 la taxe
d'habitation sur les résidences
principales est progressivement
supprimées en 2020 80% des français
seront concernés par cette suppression
2023 pour l'ensemble des contribuables
cette année la baisse des recettes pour
saint quentin en yvelines est
directement compensé par l'état ou 2021
elle sera compensée par une fraction du
produit national de tva reversés à log
l'opération pour les contribuables
le taux d'imposition appliqués par
l'agglomération reste inchangée en 2020
[Musique]
ce climax est finie à très bientôt
ciao
[Musique]